[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
25 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hi, Mark, how are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hey,
Francesc, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're going
to be interviewing someone
that I really like-- actually
two people that work very
closely with me-- about Go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, one
person who actually
sits very close to both of us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, actually.
Yeah, we're going to
have two people that
work in the developer relations
team for Go and Google Cloud
Platform.
And we're going to
be talking about why
Go is cool for the
cloud and how you can
use it, et cetera, et cetera.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we'll be
talking with Andrew Gerrand
and Chris Broadfoot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
both Australians.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
you're just going
to be surrounded by Australians.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Kind
of scared about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
After that, though,
we're going to have
a great question of the week.
We're going to talk
about some trade-offs
with BigQuery versus Dataflow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that's
a very interesting question
that apparently
some people tried
to-- like once you start trying
to decide where to go, well,
you have both.
Both can do similar things.
Which one is the best one?
So we'll discuss
that at the end.
But first, we're going to
talk about the cool thing
of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So this was a video
that came past my desk
earlier this week
that I quite liked.
If anyone's played the
EVE Online multiplayer
game-- Francesc, I
know you're a big fan.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Again, I should play
video games more often,
because I did not know
who Humble Bundle were,
and I still don't know
who EVE Fanfest look.
It looks like a cool video
game version of "Star Wars."
MARK MANDEL: Yes, so if you're
not familiar with EVE Online,
it's a literally massively
multiplayer online space
exploration and
conquest type game.
It's the sort of game where
people set up betrayals
from a year or two
years in advance.
And people lose
thousands and thousands
of dollars of real money based
on what in game currency it is.
There's stuff that's
happened in that game that
has hit relative news.
It's pretty amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Relative news.
MARK MANDEL: Relative news,
like outside of gaming news.
Yeah, it's a cool game.
I don't personally play it.
But I know people that do,
and it's pretty awesome.
But we have a video where
they have a presentation they
gave about Kubernetes
and how they
run the company behind EVE.
What I like about this
presentation that I think
is quite interesting,
apart the fact
that it gives some background
on Kubernetes and how it works,
but they talk about how they
sort of onboarded Kubernetes
into their organization
and the impetus behind it.
And sort of they break it down.
They're like, OK, so we
started building Kubernetes
like on-prem, and we
ran into some issues.
And then we started playing
with Google Cloud Platform,
and that was a lot easier.
And like we started
going that way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you
know if they were using
Container Engine directly?
MARK MANDEL: They are
using Container Engine.
They do mention it.
Basically they don't want
to manage their own masters.
They basically
went, yeah, we don't
want to manage any of
this stuff ourselves,
which is a great story for us.
But I think what's
also particularly
interesting is
how they onboarded
inside their organization and
what services they use it for.
So they sort of were
like, OK, let's start
with something least critical.
Like let's use it for our CI
systems or our build systems.
And once they sort of
did that, they were like,
this is amazing.
We want to do it more,
and so maybe use it
for our dev tools and
our authoring tools--
sort of creeping up that
critical list of stuff
inside the company.
As they talk about, they haven't
fully permeated all the way
through.
But they're trying to drive
that as much as possible.
And it's really
interesting to see
how you take this sort
of thing and say, OK,
how can we sort of
step by step bring this
into a company with the
least amount of risk?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, no,
that sounds very interesting.
I know that there's a lot
of companies out there that
are considering
moving to Kubernetes,
at least a part of it.
So listening to success stories
from others could be very good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I guess it's time to
go talk with our extra two
Australian friends.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Always, always appreciate
some more Australians.
Thank you so much
to Andrew and Chris
for joining us
this late afternoon
here in San Francisco.
How are you both doing?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's
a pleasure to be here.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah, I'm
good, answering his question.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So why don't we start by,
maybe, Chris, telling us
a little bit of who you are.
What do you do at Google?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Who am I?
So I'm Chris Broadfoot.
I joined the Cloud and Go teams
at Google about a year ago.
And I'm working on getting
the Go to run on Cloud
and get that experience
to be as good as possible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah,
I'm Andrew Gerrand.
And I work on Go.
I'm actually based
in Sydney, but I'm
visiting San Francisco
at the moment,
seeing you lovely people.
And I basically am responsible
for the Go user experience,
I guess, from APIs
to documentation
to educational things and so on.
And--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Tools.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yes,
can't forget tools.
I have some fingers
in the Cloud pies,
I guess, having done a bunch
of library work and stuff
and work with the Go
Cloud team as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: The
metaphorical Cloud pie.
ANDREW GERRAND: It's delicious.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I hope so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So since you've both worked
with Go and the Go team
for quite a while, could you
tell us a little bit about,
for the people that don't
know what Go is, what is Go
and why is it so
important and amazing?
ANDREW GERRAND: Well, so Go
is a programming language that
was developed here at Google.
And we built it as a
solution to problems
that we have here at Google.
So it's designed
with building sort
of distributed systems in mind.
And so this is really
important in the cloud space
because a lot of
the design decisions
we made in designing Go
for use inside Google
are also really
applicable to people
who build cloud software.
One of the most sort of
prominent and obvious of those
is Go's support for concurrency.
It provides a lightweight
threading model,
based around the
notion of Go routines.
And then it provides
some other things
for synchronizing
and communicating
between those Go routines
and lightweight threads.
And using those
concurrency parameters,
you can build really
nice concurrent software.
And pretty much
most of the software
that people build
in the cloud space
is concurrent in some way.
And so Go is a really
nice natural fit
for people who want to
build cloud software.
And it's nice because
it's quite approachable.
If you've used any language
which has a C-like syntax,
you'll understand vaguely what
Go code does if you see it
for the first time.
And so it's very easy
for people to spin up on.
And we've seen a lot
of our cloud customers
choose to use Go not
knowing anything about Go
and then have a really
good time doing it.
And that seems to be a story
that we hear over and over
again is that people, teams,
will try writing some Go stuff
and then they sort of
fall in love with it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Definitely
matches my experience.
I started using Go well before
I joined the Go team, just
as my choice for App Engine.
And I was surprised how
quickly I was super productive
and could write moderately
correct concurrent programs
with-- compared to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Moderately
correct, that is great.
Could you just tell
us a little bit more
about your experience
writing Go on App Engine.
Have you ran something big
that you could talk about?
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yes, so I worked
for many consecutive years
on the Santa Tracker project.
I don't know how many people
listening are familiar with it.
But basically every Christmas,
a bunch of engineers from Google
get together and write a fun
web app that tracks Santa
as he flies around the world.
And at least for the
last three or four years,
the back end has
run on App Engine.
And writing services
was relatively easy.
Obviously with something
at a large scale,
you want to do things
like load testing.
But it was relatively
straightforward to get this app
to scale to a very
large number of queries.
Obviously you want to write your
app with your particular use
case in mind.
And so, in this case, we had
a lot of very similar queries,
so things like
caching, using memcache
and Datastore were
very simple to do.
And yeah, we didn't have any
production problems really.
And App Engine scaled
to about 50 instances
to serve many thousands
of queries per second.
And the throughput
from Go was very good,
many hundreds of qps
per App Engine instance.
And they're not particularly
big instances, really.
ANDREW GERRAND: And
it's nice that since he
wrote that in the first place,
the actual Go runtime has
seen a huge overhaul.
And it's now
actually a lot faster
and can handle a lot
more concurrent load
than it used to.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
that's true, yeah.
It's been a while since I
ran load tests against it.
And improvements
to Go 1.6 probably
would make a significant
difference as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
There's another project
that I also like a lot.
If I remember correctly,
there was a Doodle
that was powered by Go.
ANDREW GERRAND: Oh, yeah.
I guess, a few
years ago now there
was a Google Doodle which
was for Thanksgiving where
you could like tweak the
turkey to-- there was a turkey
illustration, and
you could change
the feathers of the
turkey and its clothes
and stuff like that and a hat.
And it was kind of ridiculous,
but people loved it.
And you could hit
a random button,
and it would be
randomly composed
of these various things.
So when you had a customized
turkey, you could share it.
And
When you shared it, it had
to be shared as an image.
And so most of that Doodle took
place in JavaScript in the app.
But then when you
did a share, you
needed to actually share
like a JPEG of the turkey.
So the Go app would
compose the turkey image
based on the various
layers, overlays.
So it just did some
image processing
and then spat out
a generated JPEG.
And when you launch anything on
the front page of Google.com,
it kind of takes a
huge amount of load.
And Go and App Engine scaled
gracefully to meet the demand.
And we actually had a member
of the Doodle team, who'd
never used Go before,
wrote the app from scratch.
I won't say it was perfect.
I had a few review comments.
But it performed well,
and it performed reliably
and did the job.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And I
think it's still running.
Things on App
Engine, generally you
can deploy it and
still have it running.
I visited an app I deployed
maybe three or four years ago,
and it was still working.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah, I mean,
I don't know if they still
enable the share and stuff.
I don't know how they archive
the Doodles, in retrospect.
But it was certainly
nice for me because I'd
been working on the original
launch of Go and App Engine.
And you know, this was kind
of like the first person that
came along and said, you know,
I want to use it for something.
And it worked as
we expected it to.
You sort of spend all
this time building things,
and it's not until you actually
see it in the hands of a user
that you really know that
you made the right choices.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
just wanted to show,
it actually still works.
Even the Share
button still works.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We
should link to it in the--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we'll
link to it on the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
ANDREW GERRAND: Maybe
people will be tweaking--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Go
for power turkeys.
ANDREW GERRAND: After
listening to this podcast.
MARK MANDEL: So we talk a
little about scale, obviously,
in terms of load and whatnot.
But I think one of the
interesting things about Go
particularly is kind of
like gofmt, which I think
is the correct way to say it.
I know people say--
ANDREW GERRAND: Gofmt.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Gofmt.
ANDREW GERRAND: It's
spelled G-O-F-M-T.
MARK MANDEL: No, I
can't deal with that.
But I think it's
really interesting
like from the outset that
was like, this is the way
to write code.
This is the syntax format
that it needs to come in,
and that lets you scale
in terms of teams.
You want to talk a
little bit about that?
ANDREW GERRAND: One of my things
that I do in talks sometimes
is I say, raise your
hand if you've ever
had an argument with a
colleague about formatting,
like code formatting.
And it's always the entire
room puts their hands up.
And then it's like,
and keep your hand up
if you thought that was a
productive use of your time.
And all the hands go down.
And I think everyone's
had this experience where
one person likes it one
way and the other person
likes it another way.
And there's really no like--
everyone has an argument,
but there's no really
objective truth
as to what the best styles are.
And so gofmt just makes
those decisions for you.
And you just have the canonical
Go style that everyone uses.
And it's not anyone's
favorite style.
It's not like the Go
team have this opinion
about brace position or tabs
versus spaces or whatever.
We just made some
decisions, and that's it.
Yeah, I mean, it's
a really nice thing.
And we get a lot
of good feedback
from people who have
engineering teams
or-- generally, the
longer somebody's
been in the software
industry, the more they
appreciate having
gofmt, I think.
What motivated us was that at
Google, in other languages,
we have these very
meticulous style guides.
And so a lot of
code reviews end up
becoming these sort
of really fixated
on the minutia of
the code, rather than
looking at the correctness
or the API design
or the things that are
really important when
writing software.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's just
fewer things to think about.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah.
And there's actually
a really nice version
of gofmt called goimports,
which is functionally the same.
It reformats code, but it
also will look at the names
that you've used
inside the source code
and update your
import statements,
like the include or the
equivalent of include
in [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: This may be
a really stupid question.
Does goimports do what
gofmt does as well?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yes.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I always
use one after the other.
It's redundant.
You don't need to.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You'll never
see an import not used error
ever again.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah, yeah.
Or not found.
MARK MANDEL: No, I like
that sort of philosophy.
And I think that also goes
to, I think when people start
using Go sometimes
they sort of see it
as a fairly verbose language.
But I think, to a degree
also, that's part of its power
in that you can
look at it and see
what is happening as each
step through the programming
language.
There's no real magic there.
What you see is what you get.
And you can dig into
the core libraries
and be like, OK, what
is this thing doing?
And you're not like, oh,
there's like some special flag
that this magic compiler has
that only the special libraries
get to use.
It's all pretty standard stuff.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
I think that's also
indicative of a greater trend
in the software industry too.
Like the last time I
used Java was maybe
three or four years
ago, and I think
Java development has changed
significantly since then.
Although the language
has also changed,
I don't think that
the way people
approach programming is simply
because of language changes.
It's because people don't want
to spend time figuring out
why their application
behavior changes
because of configuration or some
random file that's unrelated.
And I think the
simplicity of Go kind of
reflects a change
in the way people
are approaching
things in general.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah,
I mean, I don't even
think-- like Java
cops a lot of crap
for being factories of
factories of factories
and all that kind of stuff.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: But someone
typed the word factory, right,
to create those.
It's not the language at all.
ANDREW GERRAND:
And, you know, it
is possible to write
nice Java programs.
It's just the way it is used,
the culture that grew around it
in the sort of enterprise space
or whatever, is unfortunately
overly complicated.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, and we don't
mean to disparage
just Java, I guess.
ANDREW GERRAND: No, I mean,
it's true of JavaScript.
It's true even in Python.
There are lots and
lots of different ways
to do things in Python.
And just generally in
software as a whole, I think,
it sort of started off nice.
And then it just keeps
getting more and more complex.
So Go's existence is kind of a
reaction to this sort of tide
of complexity.
But I don't think Go is the
only project in the programming
landscape that's
focused on simplicity.
I mean, predating Go is, say,
Rich Hickey with Clojure,
and he has a strong
emphasis on simplicity.
There's a great
talk that he gave,
"Simplicity Made
Easy," which talks
about a lot of these things.
The core of it is
that you actually
have to try really hard
to keep things simple.
And I think complexity
is just something
that naturally arises in nature
as well as in human endeavors.
You got to put the
brakes on a bit
sometimes to try hard to keep
things small and comprehensible
and so on.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Often you just
have to kind of redo and just
start again sometimes.
Not necessarily talking
about programming languages,
but sometimes your
code, sometimes it's
just better to redo something.
MARK MANDEL: So since
we've covered a little bit
about the origins of Go and a
little bit of the philosophy
behind it, we could talk
now a little bit about,
why do you think that Go is
so successful in the cloud
nowadays?
Like there's Docker.
There's Kubernetes.
There's so many--
basically any company
that has cloud somewhere in
the name, they're using Go.
Why do you think this is?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I
think it goes back
to what we talked about at the
very beginning of the podcast
about concurrency.
And I don't think we
mentioned networking ,
but I think Go is a fantastic
language for dealing with
networking, partly because
it's great for concurrency.
But particularly writing
web applications,
I've found that it's-- just
the standard net/http package
and all of the libraries around
it create a really nice working
environment for creating
web applications.
And I think everyone in the
community recognizes that too.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah, I think
it generally just gives you
the tools that you need to
write those kind of things.
And also I guess one of
the reasons it makes sense
that Docker, for instance,
is written in Go,
is that it spends a lot of
time talking to the operating
system.
And Go makes it really
easy to understand
the interface between Go
and the operating system.
You can just walk through
the standard library
and see where the sys
calls are being made
and how that happens.
And if you need to do more,
it's pretty straightforward
to understand how to
make the raw sys calls
or talk to lib C or
any of those things.
So it puts you a lot
closer to the system
than you would feel
in-- well, I guess,
any language that has like a
runtime, like Python or Java.
But if you're using C,
you're kind of using lib C,
and then lib C is a whole
other thing in itself.
But also Go is a
memory safe language,
so you could be
using C, but then you
have to worry about
all the security
issues that come with that.
And we continue to
see so many exploits.
The memory safety of Go is
actually a really important
feature, and one that doesn't
get spoken about much,
simply because almost all modern
languages are memory safe now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, as
a previous C++ programmer,
I know that one of my favorite
things of Go is the fact that
there's no memory corruption.
That is huge.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: No seg faults.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
little thing that people
forget about, that's amazing.
So yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Do you
also feel-- I mean,
Go is not the only language
that will combine down
to a single library.
But it seems to be the reaction
against a lot of languages that
have runtimes that are bundled,
that ease of deployment
and that sort of stuff.
Do you feel like that's
also been a big factor?
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah, a lot
of people talk about it.
On my Mac, I can build
a Linux AMD64 binary
and SCP it to a VM
somewhere, and it just works.
You don't need to worry
about any of the dependencies
or bundling or
anything like that.
I think definitely
compared to any of the--
what am I trying to say?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah, like
Node or Python or even Java,
I mean, you still have to have
some story about bundling up
your deps.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, even
also the runtime version,
you end up with things like
rbenv and tools like that
to figure out what version
you're running under,
which is often very important.
It's just a lot more code
to link against, I guess.
And having them at
runtime, it also
just makes things a
little less predictable.
ANDREW GERRAND: And I
guess in the cloud sense,
in a Docker container, you can
create a Docker container that
just has the Go binary in it
and nothing else and that's it.
And that's kind of nice.
It's a very easy
thing to understand
in this world that's complicated
and difficult to understand.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So for people that are
already convinced on using Go
and using Go in the cloud,
what are the different ways
that they can run Go on
Google Cloud Platform?
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yes, so there are
many ways that vary
from very managed
to not being managed at all.
So some of my favorites
are Google App Engine.
I don't like messing with
deployment scripts and things
like that.
I mostly write web applications.
So they're a really great fit.
We have two sort of
flavors, I guess.
So there's App Engine
standard environment.
And this is what we used to
call a sandbox environment,
has quite a few
restrictions around how
you program your application.
So you're not likely
to run an existing Go
application directly
on App Engine standard.
But you can basically
do that with App Engine
flexible environment, which
has far fewer restrictions.
You have a main function
and a main package.
So you basically run the
same application outside
of App Engine as you
do on your desktop
or on a different
cloud provider.
We also have Kubernetes, which
is essentially an open source
version of the deployment
system we use at Google,
which is called Borg.
And this lets you
run your application
on many different nodes on any
compute provider very easily.
There's also Compute
Engine, which
is basically just a bare VM.
And this means you have to run
your own deployment scripts
and startup scripts and
manage all of that yourself.
However, we do provide things
like kernel patches and things
like that on the fly.
So it's still very different
to having a computer sitting
under your stairs, right.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah, also
in the Compute Engine case,
you basically just get nothing,
in terms of scaling and so on.
But then in the
App Engine cases,
either App Engine
standard or flex,
you can take advantage of the
order scaling infrastructure
that we have.
So if your app gets a lot of
incoming requests suddenly,
a load spike, it
can quickly spin up
various instances, more
instances of your app,
and serve more request volume.
The key advantage that
standard has over flex
is that it can spin up
instances very, very quickly.
The entire
infrastructure is built
around kind of keeping hot
spares of blank slate instances
that can then just basically
copy your app and launch it.
Whereas with flex,
each new instance
has to spin up a new VM
to serve that instance.
So if you can work within
the standard App Engine
environment, it's
actually a really nice way
to build software.
It doesn't let you do things
like write to the file system.
And you need to use our APIs
to make like external network
requests and so on.
But we've done our
best to kind of make
it feel really natural to
do that from inside Go.
And generally if you use the
App Engine standard packages,
you will write an
app that will scale.
That's kind of the whole
premise of App Engine
is that we give you the APIs
to use that if you use them,
you won't write
an unscalable app.
I mean, it's definitely
still possible,
but the way it's designed kind
of makes it natural to do it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's
also great for small apps.
As I said before, I have
a multitude of toy apps
that continue running
without any oversight at all.
And I think that's another-- a
real strength of the App Engine
platform.
It's very lightweight.
ANDREW GERRAND: Oh,
and App Engine standard
will run zero instances of
your app if no one is using it.
So you don't even
pay for your app
when people aren't
using it, which
is a definite advantage
over the VM-based.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we
had a couple episodes ago
interviewed Humble Bundle.
And they run the
whole infrastructure
basically on App Engine,
and they were talking
about all of these benefits.
If they get a huge spike in
traffic, they don't care.
Everything just works.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
so I should mention
another thing
we're working on is
a set of packages and libraries
that sort of bridge these
gaps so that if you start
with App Engine standard
and need to do something
a little more special,
you can move to the flexible
environment, previously known
as Managed VMs.
And to sort of move between
these different deployment
modes and not have to
rewrite your application
because applications
should be agnostic of where
they're deployed.
You should just write
your application
and be able to deploy
it wherever you like
and however you like.
So that's another focus and
real goal of the Google Cloud
Platform right now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I got to say
that one of my favorite
things out of all the packages
is the way authentication
works, with basically Go
on any of the clouds.
It is super simple.
It's basically two
lines of code saying,
just get the
default credentials.
And everything just works.
That is super nice.
Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: So if people have
been listening the episode,
and they're particularly
interested in learning Go
or possibly Go on Google
Cloud Platform, what
are your favorite ways
of learning those things?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Well,
I think, first of all,
you should learn
Go, and the best way
to do that is the Go
tour, which Andrew wrote.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah,
its tour.golang.org.
And you can just go
through, use a web browser
and learn the features
of the language.
MARK MANDEL: I've done that.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah.
I think it's a pretty
good way to get started.
I definitely recommend like
having a project in mind,
like something simple that you
can just like try and make.
I think a lot of people try
to absorb a lot of information
in the abstract, before
trying to apply it.
That's just my personal
style is to actually
have something in mind.
And then if you want to
move into the cloud space,
we have cloud.google.com/go,
which has a great introductory
app, a bookshelf app
for organizing books.
MARK MANDEL: Something
we all need to do.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREW GERRAND:
Yes, I meticulously
catalog my book
collection in this app.
Not really.
But it's a great demo of how
all the pieces fit together
in the deployment story
and all that stuff.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: There's
also a couple other resources
if you go into
the cloud console.
And I think if you
press App Engine,
there are some guided flows.
So you don't even
need to download
the SDK to your local machine
or anything like that.
You use the Cloud Shell, which
is basically a virtual machine
that runs the cloud tools.
And so you do everything
through a web interface.
And that's a pretty
great way to just get
a feel for Google Cloud
Platform and App Engine.
And then there's also
another repository
where we're adding
a lot of samples
to and sort of
consolidating samples.
And so that's github.com/googl
ecloudplatform/golang-samples.
We'll put a link in.
And yeah, so you can
just take a look in there
and see a bunch of
different samples
and how things fit together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're pretty
much out of time,
but is there anything else
that you would like to add?
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Check out the turkeys.
ANDREW GERRAND: I
think that rabbits
are the superior domestic pet.
I'd just thought I'd
throw that out there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Better than gophers?
ANDREW GERRAND: I don't know
anyone who keeps a gopher.
If you keep a gopher,
please write to me,
adg@golang.org, and tell
me your experiences.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thank you very much.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thank you
MARK MANDEL: Thanks, guys.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so
much to Andrew and Chris
for joining us today.
That was a really
interesting conversation,
and it was an absolute
pleasure to talk to you both.
But we have a really interesting
question of the week.
Francesc, would you
like to head that off?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so it's a question that
comes to us through
the-- I forgot the name.
MARK MANDEL: Slack channel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Through
the Slack channel, exactly.
We have a podcast Slack channel
in the Google Cloud Platform
community.
And the question
is, OK, so when do
you transform your data
in BigQuery via queries
versus Dataflow for ETL?
MARK MANDEL: It's an
interesting question, right,
because in theory you
could do it either way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so I think that the thing
to keep in mind here
is that BigQuery
is a very specific tool with a
very specific use case, which
is basically log analysis.
It will do more than that.
It will do, basically, analysis
of any kind of structured data
where the analysis that
you're trying to do
matches pretty much what you
could consider a SQL query.
And for those that don't
know about what ETL is,
basically ETL is a way
of processing data.
It's about extract,
transform, and load.
So it's like you
extract the data,
you transform it in
some way, and then
you store it into
your data warehouse.
And BigQuery is more
about once that data
has been loaded into
the data warehouse,
you can extract information
out of that data.
So if you're doing something
like, you have a lot of data,
and you want to do an
average over all the values,
or you want to find
some specific rows
and stuff like that,
that is basically
what BigQuery was built for.
But BigQuery doesn't
do everything.
There's things like,
for instance, if you're
trying to do things with images
or really anything that is not
structured, not just
text, it's not really
going to work with BigQuery.
So in that case, you
should use Dataflow.
And Dataflow, it's
basically-- if you have never
heard about Dataflow, but
you've heard about MapReduce,
Dataflow is like
a generalization
of what MapReduce does.
So instead of having
just a-- so MapReduce--
this is an interview question.
How many phases
does MapReduce have?
MARK MANDEL: How many faces?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Like eyes, nose
and ears, and like, mouth?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, phases.
Making fun of my accent.
MARK MANDEL: No, I didn't
understand you, I promise.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So how many
phases are there in MapReduce?
MARK MANDEL: That's a
great question, Francesc.
How many phases are
there in MapReduce?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One
could say map and reduce.
No, there's map,
shuffle, and reduce.
But you don't say
map, shuffle, reduce,
because it could be too long.
But so basically, you
get those three phases,
and you make them composable.
So it's like a generalization.
You can have as many
phases as you want.
So that allows you to
do whatever you want.
So it's really powerful.
So if you want to do something
that matches the BigQuery use
case, go with BigQuery.
Otherwise, Dataflow
will be there for you.
And Dataflow is also very
good for a specific use
case, which is real-time
analysis and streaming.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
That makes sense.
So if you want to
like window your data
or know exactly how
many times something's
happened in the last half
hour or something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
There's also-- I've seen
some of them was basically
demonstrating how to
implement the Twitter--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
hashtags around trending,
that you can implement that with
Dataflow quite easily really.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Excellent.
All right, so it sounds like
if I have structured data,
it fits in BigQuery, and
it hits that paradigm,
I should just use BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: But if I sit sort
of outside of that paradigm,
then I might as
well use Dataflow
because it gives me more
flexibility in what I
need to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, if you
can use BigQuery, use BigQuery.
You will not regret it.
And if you cannot use
it, then use Dataflow,
and you can write
whatever you need.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, that sounds
like awesome stuff.
But I think we're
going to be traveling
around a little bit, Francesc,
in the next couple of weeks.
You going to be
anywhere special?
Is there anything happening
in the next few weeks
that we should mention?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going
to this incredible place,
the happiest place in the Earth.
MARK MANDEL: Disneyland.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
No, Mountain View.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we're going
to be in Mountain
View for Google I/O.
And that's going to
be pretty awesome.
I'm working on my slides now.
No, just kidding.
My slides are pretty much ready.
I'm going to be talking
about Cloud Spin.
And you were talking about--
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing a
session on multiplayer games
with Firebase.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds very interesting.
You're doing a lot of
video games lately.
MARK MANDEL: I like video games.
They're fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is cool.
And after that, I will
go to GoTo Chicago.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
first time there.
I will be talking
about Go tooling.
Very excited about that one.
MARK MANDEL: I'm excited
because I'll be getting-- well,
I'll be staying up till 1 AM
to do a presentation for GDG
Melbourne.
That's going to be lots of fun.
And after that, I probably
will be heading off to-- yes,
I'll be doing several stints
off to Minneapolis, actually,
in June, which will
be lots of fun.
But one event that
I definitely want
to bring up that's
going to be on June 3
is Change the Game
development summit here
in San Francisco on June 3
at the Google headquarters
here in San Francisco.
So if you're interested in
game development on the cloud,
multiplayer games, analytics,
big data with games,
all that sort of good stuff,
definitely come check us out.
It's a free event.
You can come down.
We definitely still
have seats available.
I'll be presenting
there with some people.
Pocket Gems will be there.
Kabam will be there.
Some other fun people like that.
So we'd love to see you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Maybe I should mention
that, right after that,
I will be gone for a week.
Yeah, so I will be biking from
San Francisco to Los Angeles.
Yeah, so I'm going to be
doing the AIDS/LifeCycle,
and I'm looking for donations.
MARK MANDEL: I've
already donated.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
thank you so much.
So yeah, I don't know if
we-- that week maybe we'll
do a podcast on the
road or something.
MARK MANDEL: Or
we'll prerecord it.
We'll sort things out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll
find something out.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, Francesc, thank you so
much for joining me yet again
for another episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you so much,
Mark, for being
here and helping me
understand two
other Australians.
Sometimes the accent gets hard.
MARK MANDEL: No problem.
And definitely speak
to you next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
talk to you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]